in its time the dragonpit was a marvel
of the world full grown Targaryen
dragons nested beneath its massive dome
and even on the darkest nights the walls
seemed to glow with the fire of the
great beasts inside as had the site's
previous occupant the Sept of
remembrance and may ago the cruel
blasted it with dragon fire during
morning prayers the screams of the dying
men echoed through King's Landing all
day and a pall of ash and smoke hung
over the city for a week but as it
dissipated so too did the rebellion of
the faith militant the Sept of
remembrance faded from memory and Meg or
decided to replace a monument to the
gods with a monument to his family the
dragon pit labor proved elusive however
for after the red cape was finished
megalo had hosted a three-day feast for
all the builders stonemasons and
carpenters who had work to build it at
its conclusion he slaughtered them so
that only he would know the castles
secrets so many men fled the
construction of the dragon pit but
maegor was forced to employ the
prisoners of the city dungeons
supplemented by skilled and ignorant
builders from across the Narrow Sea for
more than a century the Targaryen housed
their dragons in the dragon pit the
dragons are not horses to be stable door
hounds to be kenneled with each
generation the Dragons became less less
massive less Swift
less long-lived and less invulnerable
during the dance of dragons to Targaryen
factions killed a handful of their
families dragons while fighting each
other a frenzied mob even broke into the
dragon pit and slaughtered the five
dragons chained there though the last
managed to bring down the roof of the
Great Dome on its assailants the Dragons
never recovered their former strength or
numbers perhaps their line had been too
broken or perhaps others intervened to
break it further but the last dragon
grew no larger than a cat and its death
and Egham third of his name the epithet
dragon Bay
what is a dragon pit without dragons the
roof remained where it had fallen the
great bronze doors rusted and fell off
their hinges prostitutes cavorted were
fantastic creatures at once fed and
slept then came Daenerys now dragons
once again darken the sky but they will
never darken the dragon pit again
Daenerys has learned the folly of
chaining her dragons the dragon pit is
and will remain a ruin of a bygone age
when kings and queens flew high above
their country
hey everybody as requested new Game of
Thrones talking about some more
Targaryen history this time we saw a
little bit of this play out during the
course of season 7 and some of the
things that Jon Snow and Daenerys talked
about and also some visual metaphors
mirroring events that have happened on
the TV show thus far with Cersei the
cruel maegor the cruel if you are
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything we're doing
videos till season 8 gets here and I'm
still doing that DVD giveaway I'll
explain at the end of the video but
starting with the really fun stuff first
so make or the cruel is the Targaryen
king that built the dragon pit but it
all came after this buildup in faith
militant uprising which is very similar
to the things that happened during
season 6 of the TV show his rise to
power was just as bloody and
backstabbing as Circe's rise to power he
took power from his brother in his the
first who you could kind of consider a
weak indecisive king that allowed the
faith to gain enough power to create the
faith militant the first faith militant
uprising as things started to spiral out
of control chaos is a ladder style
that's when maegor took his moment to
seize power the same way Cersei seized
power by blowing up the great Sept but
just to put it in context they were the
sons of Aegon the conquerer so this is
happening right after Aegon the
conquerer has died his son Inez becomes
king he's somewhat of a weak King so
circumstances lead to a faith militant
uprising that Meg or then seizes power
and puts down using the dragons to blow
up the great Sept of the day which was
called the Sept of remembrance that they
talked about in this clip so he
basically tore down what was the symbol
of the people's faith and put the symbol
of his family's power in its place so
it's like I'm gonna build the dragon pit
here but he had also been finishing the
red keep in a very red wedding e-type
twist killed everybody at the great
feast that he held after it was done you
see how George R Martin weaves themes in
and out of history names recur events
seem very similar to events that
happened in the past the Lannisters send
their regards
meg or sends his regards but because he
had killed off all these skilled
laborers to protect the secrets of the
red keep he had to scrape the bottom of
the barrel to build the dragon pit but
he did get overseers from Mir in
volantis which is why you see a lot of
visual similarities to the great pit of
daznak when the dome isn't on top of it
like at the end of this clip Varys says
what is a dragon pit without dragons it
looks an awful lot like Daz knacks pit
the Coliseum but then the longer they'd
been chained up as you've heard they
grew weaker and weaker slowly dying off
I love the way that when Kai burns
narrating this he also implies that
people within the inner circle also
hastened the demise of the Dragons so on
top of the fact that they were just
genetically becoming weaker and weaker
there were also people that slowly tried
to kill them off even faster but the
dance of the Dragons is probably the
single most cataclysmic event in the
eventual downfall of the Dragons
themselves just because there are so
many dragons on different factions
killing each other so within the span of
a few years you lose a lot of your
dragons in addition to a bunch of the
peasants storming the dragon pit and
killing the five remaining ones that
were staying there but side note the
dance of the Dragons is also one of the
leading candidates for the prequel
series that they're developing there are
a couple notable events in history that
George are Martin has already said that
they're not doing for the prequel series
the dance of the Dragons is one of the
few big ones that he hasn't said
anything about just meaning that it's
still on the list as the last of the
Dragons that had been housed in the
dragon pit were being killed by the
peasants one of them actually belonged
to a prince named Joffrey valerian which
is just funny thinking about Joffrey and
present-day names recur several times
throughout history so it's just funny to
hear that there was a Joffrey of the day
but you all probably remember that
moment where Jon Snow hands that tiny
little dragon skull to Daenerys Qyburn
narrates that the final dragon was no
larger than a cat so you just picture a
sir pounce sighs dragon running around
the red keep chasing around other cats
that would actually be pretty funny but
because the king of the time Aegon the
third was named dragon bane it's a good
reminder that the affectations that the
citizens give the kings and queens
aren't always meant to honor them
sometimes they're meant to
them like maegor being called maegor the
cruel was not a name to imply how
awesome he was sir see finally becoming
queen getting what she wants
sounds like she's also headed for a name
that will mock her even though you got
what you wanted everybody hates you and
you're left alone the other funny thing
though is that when Varys says you know
what is a dragon pit without dragon see
the doors blown off talking about how
it's just left in ruins it was later
used by prostitutes entertaining their
customers which is a funny image by
vagrants just sleeping there homeless
people just camping out but probably the
last big thing that it was used for in a
practical sense was as a mass grave
during a big outbreak of the plague they
called it the great spring sickness it
happened about a hundred years before
events on the TV show paints a very
specific picture for what the possible
future of the kingdom is in King's
Landing alone over a million people that
could be turned into the army of the
Dead just like massive numbers of people
died during the great spring sickness
but getting into season 8 stuff actually
people were talking about how the actors
will be in places that they've never
been before even though I want to see
Cersei stay relatively local to the red
keep just because that place is so
important to her the Iron Throne has
been so important to her this whole time
I would love to see her sitting in the
ruins of it during this Daenerys vision
here making this come to pass and some
twist on the knight King making it to
King's Landing but if they have
confirmed that all of the main actors
will be going places that they'd never
gone before it just implies that
eventually Cersei will either board one
of your on ships and they'll sail
somewhere else or she'll be somewhere
else in a Westeros they say all the main
actors are going places they've never
been before what do you think that means
for Circe's character who has not left
King's Landing since season 1 literally
the last time that she was not in King's
Landing was in the first two episodes of
the series during season 1 when they
went to Winterfell in an episode two
when they were still on their way back
to King's Landing but let me know in the
comments if you still want me to do more
videos for these bonus features that
they've been dropping the last couple of
days some of them are actually really
cool but congratulations to the latest
DVD giveaway winner if the new a boy
please private message me so I can get
your contact details there's a new round
in this video I'll just announce
the winner the next time I post Game of
Thrones so you can click here for all my
Star Wars the last Jedi Easter eggs and
you can click here for that other Game
of Thrones prophecy trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight